some were left to speculate that cicada
is not a man at all
but an immortal monster all we know for
sure
is his body count 152 victims
and rising wait what
i knew he never caught cicada but he
never stops killing
flash did everything he could but cicada
killed more people than zoom
or even the red death and the way the
city saw the flash
his legacy it was never the same
hey everybody it's charlie this is going
to be my flash episode 12 video there
were so many easter eggs in this episode
and how about that red death teaser so
we'll break it all down i'll explain
what's going on
because they foreshadowed a lot of big
things coming between future villains
that they'll probably get to on the show
in one form or another and all the
crisis on infinite earth stuff that
we've been spiraling towards
there's a new round of the flash ring
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment
about the episode on the video
the episode itself was also kind of like
the by our merch episode
most of the stuff that you saw in the
flash museum all that merch and some of
the stuff that people were wearing like
what caitlyn was wearing
is actual real life merch that you could
go walk out and buy
today obviously spoilers for the episode
if you haven't seen it yet top 10 wtf in
easter eggs here we go number 10
norah's journal so she's talking to
reverse flash even though he doesn't
appear during the episode
there's this real cat and mouse game
going on between her and sherlock
who pretty much figured things out by
the end of the episode
so it's just a matter of time before he
fully outs her even though he had the
chance during this week's episode
it's more about nora doing the wrong
things that she feels like for the right
reasons like oh it's worth it that i'm
being kind of terrible and lying to all
these people because the ultimate goal
is to save them so if i can save them
then everything i do will be totally
worth it
one of the early foreshadowing moments
is when barry has the joke about get
ready for the race of your life because
literally that's going to be happening
for her later this season like we're
building towards nora making a sacrifice
like she's been kind of selfish this
past season wanting to spend time with
her family and willing to alter the
timeline
causing repercussions in other people's
lives because she wants to save her
father even though she's
trying to be as good about it as
possible she's still making the very
mistake
of making the selfish choice like i want
to change my future so i can be with my
parents together in the future and in
fact it was her
that caused the satellite's trajectory
to change when she helped barry take it
down in the season four finale
that put them in this mess so her
changing the timeline already
has created problems for other people
notably cicada
in grace who's in the hospital right now
early theory she sacrifices herself
at the end of the season but things wind
up in a much better place than they
would have otherwise like we wind up
with our tornado twins and we get this
big payoff if you even look at the
scrabble board here they're
foreshadowing tornado twins look it says
toy for shui brother who's her brother
the other half of the tornado twins so
it just seems like they're
telling us that this is going to come to
pass sometime in the future
but number nine irises central city
citizen newspaper
you kind of see the logic in putting her
office right next to ralph so she's
gonna use that space
she needs a photographer and what a
surprise cisco meets a cute young
bartender who's a photographer looking
for work
they got the office at the end of the
episode so we'll see how quickly she has
that up and running but i'm guessing
within the next couple of episodes
but this is basically what iris is going
to be doing for the rest of the season
day to day when she's not helping team
flash out with something specific they
should be tracking down her own stories
working on stuff in the background
there were a couple killer frost easter
eggs when she's on the ice and they're
all skating around
the sweater that she's wearing is
actually the same sweater from a
real-life
killer frost figure that you can go out
and buy like this is something that dc
direct actually sells
we learned that killer frost really
likes staying up late watching movies
her favorite directors are john woo
and john hughes very different types of
films
one is hardcore action the other john
hughes films are typically coming of age
stories
so it's like they're trying to say that
killer frost is the core demographic of
the cw
people who like those kinds of genres
sherlock makes the joke about his
partner being watson
and him sleeping with his fourth wife
number eight nora gets stuck
in grace's mind and it's the central
city police department which they then
pay off later when barry and iris go in
but the story that she tells her about
phasing the plane that was from season
five episode one those when she wally
and barry
phased the plane to save everyone which
itself was an easter egg for the flash
new 52 comic book i think that was
actually issue one it was one of the
first couple of issues of the new 52 run
but it was buried by himself in the
comic book version and on the tv show
was the three of them together
the liquid kitty bar that cisco and
elongated man go to is
actually an easter egg for a real life
bar called the liquid kitty in the west
la area it's just a punk rock bar
that i think is closed down now but
number seven barry and iris enter nora's
memories and it's almost an exact copy
of grace's memory with a couple changes
like they
referenced noir isn't that joe west's
granddaughter remember there was
actually an easter egg in an earlier
episode where joe west was being honored
and eventually
became the captain of the police
department so maybe they'll pay that off
this season
but number six the flash museum and all
those easter eggs
like i said pretty much all the merch
that you see in here is
real merch that you could actually go
out and buy right now so that's why it's
like the buy my merch episode of the
flash but there are a couple very
specific easter eggs that the camera
focuses on
so all the figurines all just normal
stuff normal merch that you would expect
but there are a couple of comic books
there's a cicada comic book from the
jeff johns run i've talked about that in
a couple of the trailer videos that i've
done
but they also have a rebirth era grodd
comic book right underneath it
foreshadowing the grodd episode that
we're going to get
later this season i don't know which
episode exactly it's going to be but
it's supposed to be a grodd king shark
team up episode
that's why way back in episode 1 nora
made the reference to grodd vs king
shark because we were gonna get that
episode later this season so this grog
comic book is just foreshadowing that
number five though this is a really cool
one red death name drop
foreshadowing him potentially being a
future villain in a new season
within the context of the episode it was
captain singh saying
that cicada had been a worse villain
than any of the previous speedsters that
barry had ever faced
killed more people than zoom killed more
people than the red death
they also say at that point he had
become immortal because of all the dark
matter that's slowly taking over his
body like he's been getting more and
more powerful
the whole thing with the red death
though is that they would have to do a
slightly different version of the
character but i would love to see the
flash tv show
set up a dark multiverse storyline is
like the next
really big crossover idea after crisis
on infinite earths
because honestly where do you go after
crisis on infinite earths
you do something like dark knight's
metal but it'd have to be a slightly
different version because those are all
the nightmare versions of batman and as
far as we know they can't
really do batman so whoever their
version of the red death would wind up
being it would have to be a different
character but you just imagine it's the
same idea just a nightmare
version of the flash that wears an
armor-looking costume
it's like the abracadabra episode of
flash season 3 where he rattles off the
names of all the flash's villains that
he faces
in davao was one of them then during
season 4 devoe became the villain
so think of the red death name drop is
the same kind of thing like he might not
be the villain of next season but it
just sounds like they're foreshadowing
that at some point yeah we're gonna try
and do a version of the red death
you may have also detected the voice in
the background of the flash museum
narrating all those different areas was
robert pracardo
from star trek voyager but he's also
been on a billion other sci-fi tv series
so even if you didn't remember his name
you probably recognized his voice a
little bit
but number four the reverse flash golem
so we learned about the defense
mechanisms that both nora and grace have
in
their minds nora's just happens to be
the reverse flash because she's so
preoccupied with him so it chases them
around they do kind of explain a little
bit about how their powers work
typically it's the dreamer that controls
what the rules of physics are within
their dream
but the funny thing is is when they're
running from that reverse flash costume
is that the phone rings on the counter
behind them and the ringtone is
the real life theme song of the flash tv
show that plays
all the time so just a really cool meta
easter egg
[Music]
number three grace loses her we
learned that she hates the flash
therefore hates nora you're the daughter
of the flash i'm gonna stop you i'm
gonna help my uncle
so things just go completely off the
rails with her storyline
even though they escaped the whole point
of them going in was to help wake her
out of her coma and she just absolutely
flatly refused to wake up
really big twist that i did not expect
so grace is still i feel like the key
to the cicada storyline but in a much
different way than i previously had
expected
two sherlock first outs and then saves
nora
pretty much proving that he knows
exactly what's going on especially after
he talks to barry
say who was that defense mechanism which
suit was it oh the reverse flash suit
that's interesting that kind of lets me
know that she's preoccupied with him so
he's just put two and two together that
the reverse flash is the other set of
handwriting
inside her special journal so the whole
thing here is i think that he's just
waiting for the right opportunity for
nora to either out herself but he had
her dead to rights like she was just
standing there frozen
and everybody was getting impatient
before he very purposefully stepped in
and saved her so he has her where he
wants her i think there'll probably be
some conversation between the two of
them where he confronts her about it
later
but probably the number one wtf was the
way they ended the episode with grace
talking to her mind space cicada vowing
to help cicada but his grace underneath
the cicada costume that she's talking to
in the shard of dark matter that we
learn about that's embedded in her head
starts glowing the same way that is
glowing in cicada's chest
so it implies that she has metahuman
powers now but we don't know exactly how
they work but it has something to do
with this weird mindspace cicada
in the fact that she's seeing herself as
cicada implies that maybe
she'll be able to control cicada at some
point like it's going to be some weird
link between the two of them
but quick note on cisco's hookup at the
bar the person who he was talking to is
named camilla
she's actually going to be a character
later this season like i said she's a
photographer who's out of work iris
needs a photographer
they had a moment of chemistry so
they're just gonna continue that in
future episodes i don't know how many
more episodes she'll be in this season
though
but let me know in the comments what was
your favorite easter egg from the
episode even if it wasn't one that i
mentioned during the video
who knows that they're ever gonna do
godspeed but red death is a really cool
teaser for them to drop so what will
happen is i'll do a new trailer video
tomorrow there's new captain marvel and
a whole bunch of super bowl trailers on
the way
so click here for my new avengers
endgame agents of shield
trailer video and click here for my and
click here to re-watch that birds of
prey
trailer thank you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome
i'll see you guys tonight